Kong: Skull Island is packed with eye candy
and giant monster fights, but director Jordan
Vogt-Roberts also stuffed the movie full of
pop culture Easter eggs, referencing everything
from anime to Jurassic Park.
"Hold onto your butts."
"Hooold onto your butts."
And Kong is especially full of video game
Easter eggs.
Here are all the ones you missed in Kong:
Skull Island.
Metal Gear Solid
Jordan Vogt-Roberts is a massive Metal Gear
Solid fan.
He told Den of Geek:
"That's one of the most important franchises
to me on the planet.
Not even just as a video game, but as a piece
of media."
So it's no surprise that the director couldn't
help but put a little bit of Metal Gear into
Skull Island.
Remember the name of the ramshackle boat that
John C. Reilly's character builds?
"She's called the Gray Fox."
If that sounds familiar to you, you've probably
played a lot of video games.
Gray Fox is a recurring character in the Metal
Gear franchise, and according to Vogt-Roberts,
Gray Fox was only supposed to be the tip of
the iceberg when it came to Skull Island's
Metal Gear Solid references.
Screenwriter Dan Gilroy wrote a sequence in
which Tom Hiddleston's character breaks into
a military base, and Vogt-Roberts claims he
was going to "get very Metal Gear with it"
before the scene was cut.
The Legend of Zelda
Samuel L. Jackson's group of pilots, the Sky
Devils, get a lot of screen-time throughout
Kong.
That gives viewers plenty of time to study
their uniforms—and Zelda fans may have noticed
that the Sky Devils insignia looks a lot like
the Hyrule Wingcrest, which made its first
appearance in The Legend of Zelda: The Ocarina
of Time (my favorite game of all time, FYI).
The resemblance isn't exact, but according
to Vogt-Roberts, the similarity is 100% intentional.
Pokémon
Skull Island's scariest creatures aren't giant
apes or bamboo spiders—they're those freaky
two-legged reptiles.
"The Iwis won't speak their name.
But I call them Skullcrawlers."
"Why?"
"Cuz it sounds neat."
But despite their ferociousness, the Skullcrawlers
have a fairly cuddly origin.
According to a behind-the-scenes feature at
Wired, Vogt-Roberts gave the special effects
team a single reference to get them started:
Cubone, one of the very first Pokémon.
It's the kind of thing that's impossible to
unsee: both creatures have long heads that
look like skulls and lizard-like bodies.
Of course, there's one big difference between
the two: the Skullcrawlers just look like
they're wearing another creature's skull.
Cubone actually is—the skull belongs to
his mother, which is much more terrifying.
Mega Man and Metroid
The Legend of Zelda isn't the only big video
game franchise that snuck into the costumes
of Kong: Skull Island.
Some of the helmets donned by the pilots in
the movie resemble those worn by the heroes
in Mega Man, Metroid, and the classic Gundam
franchise.
Of course, Samus and Mega Man sport helmets
with blocky extra parts.
The flight helmets in Skull Island are a lot
more realistic, and you have to study the
designs closely to see the similarities.
3D extrusions like the caps around Mega Man's
ears have been reduced to 2D paintjobs, and
the color schemes are totally different.
Still, if you look hard enough, you'll notice
that many of Mega Man and Samus' iconic silhouettes
reappear on the helmets.
That's enough for us to count it, even if
the geeks in us wish that the similarities
were just a little more pronounced.
Resident Evil
Kong: Skull Island introduced King Kong with
a stunning 360-degree shot that zooms through
several helicopter cockpits while circling
the giant ape.
It's an exciting way to highlight Skull Island's
biggest star, and in the context of the movie,
it goes a long way towards showing just how
big Kong really is.
Well, guess what?
Vogt-Roberts totally stole the shot from a
video game.
He's not shy about it, either.
He said,
"That's a very video game shot to me.
That shot actually was inspired by a cinematic
in a Resident Evil game."
Vogt-Roberts doesn't identify which Resident
Evil he's ripping off—there are a lot of
games out there, and almost as many helicopter
crashes in them—but fans think he's probably
talking about Operation Raccoon City, a non-canon
third-person shooter.
Shadow of the Colossus
If you're making a movie about giant monsters,
it makes sense that you'd look to the most
famous video game about giant monsters for
inspiration.
That's exactly what Vogt-Roberts did.
He told Den of Geek:
"Shadow Of The Colossus was a huge influence
on me on this movie….the colossi in those
games have such a slow, melancholy, morose
quality to them.
And the sense of scale...I think and I hope
that Kong has a similar vibe in the film."
In other words, if you go into Kong: Skull
Island looking for visuals borrowed from Shadow
of the Colossus, you won't find them.
If you think of Kong as spiritual descendent
of the titular Colossi, however, you'll spot
Shadow of the Colossus' influence throughout
the film.
Like Shadow's Colossi, Kong is a majestic
and tragic figure.
It's no surprise that they go hand in hand.
Journey
In Journey, your player has to cross a vast
desert, trying to reach a glowing mountain
in the distance.
You can connect with other players, but you
can only communicate with actions or musical
notes.
It's a strange, ethereal game that's been
called "a kind of non-denominational religious
experience for players."
Kong director Jordan Vogt-Roberts' review
isn't quite so wordy, but gives the game just
as much praise:
"Journey is one of my favorite things… ever."
As such, Vogt-Roberts snuck Journey's illuminated
mountain into Skull Island's landscape.
The peaks are a little more jagged in Kong,
but the silhouette is unmistakable.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!